alors ma Géraldine
tu es hautaine bourgeoise bobo
c'est l'image que les gens ont de toi et
c'est très bien parce que tu assumes et
c'est ça qui me plaît chez toi c'est que
tu assumes et non seulement tu assumes
mais tu as pu sur le trait sur la
caricature de toi-même et ça me fait
plaisir parce que je trouve que c'est
formidable de faire ça tu es cash à
chaque émission tu enfile ton trait tu
pars à la guerre et
ouais pour venir et tu es pas là pour
rigoler et en même temps et c'est ça que
je trouve génial c'est que au début on
te trouvait évidemment au thème etc tout
ce que j'ai dit tes corseté et là tu as
des boutonné des boutonné l'école de la
chemise et là on est sur un décolleté
mais
elle a une cote parce que maintenant en
plus en plus de tout ça tu es devenu
sexy tu es devenu
rigolote parce que tu as tu avais un peu
de mal à parce que je te connais tes
timide donc tu avais un petit peu de mal
à danser à jouer le jeu de la darka etc
là maintenant tu y vas et donc pour
toutes ces raisons je te mets un neuf tu
sais que
c'est le conseil de classe Géraldine
Valérie
aujourd'hui et l'abominable de Rungis
[Rires]
[Musique]
voilà
donc Valérie allez le petit nouveau Hugo
moi je vais commencer tout de suite par
la note et puis après je dirais pourquoi
d'accord donc moi je lui ai mis la note
de 10 sur 10
bonjour
ce soir
[Rires]
dans un instant il est comme un fou
parce qu'il a été découvert dans quoi et
c'est lui qui croyait son étoile
il a eu raison parce qu'il est
incroyable
quand tu as chanté je te jure
j'ai eu des poils qui sont apparus même
je te jure frère
il était habité il a fait la version
aussi pour le ski je crois ma première
école
donc bon au-delà du fait que je sois
dans 99,9% des cas d'accord avec toi et
que nos opinions en règle générale
[Rires]
donc finalement
c'est vrai que tu me fais bosser mon ami
et donc voilà donc je suis très souvent
d'accord avec toi mais c'est pas la
raison pour laquelle je te mets 10 c'est
quoi je te mets 10 parce que parce que
je trouve que tu argumentes toujours
d'une façon exemplaire je trouve que tu
es parmi nous celle qui a chaque fois le
plus de structures dans tes
argumentations
et je te trouve aussi très charismatique
tu es une très belle femme et comment tu
ne dragues pas
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc pour faire simple en gros tu
es ma chroniqueuse préférée tu l'étais
déjà avant que j'intègre l'équipe et en
fait te connaître maintenant en vrai tu
ne fais que confirmer que je t'adore
[Applaudissements]
9 pour Valérie j'ai oublié le petit
magnéto si on fait un petit magnétoile
un temps fou à le faire et donc
forcément puis-je radis tu as envie de
te voir est-ce que tu te regardes ah non
non
j'ai envie d'entendre parce que vu les
conneries qui va dire là j'ai envie de
le voir en
[Applaudissements]
premier
tout le temps à mort sur les chiens et
les chats et qu'est-ce que tu fais des
autres animaux
laisse-moi parler
si la France
la dernière fois on avait Anthony qui
était malvoyant qui avait pas avec son
chien mais
on s'en fout de toi
excellent émission entre les
influenceurs et les créateurs de contenu
tu vois non mais je sais je j'ai compris
quand même Maxime j'ai pas l'air
complètement débile comme ça
[Applaudissements]
coûte combien par rapport à un paquet de
cigarettes ça vous intéresse pas ma
question
[Applaudissements]
j'ai mis donner des leçons et vous avez
raison mais le donneur de leçons faites
mais c'est pas une question de donner
des informations
dans ton modèle à toi ça veut dire que
ce sont les femmes qui doivent
s'habituer au vieux pervers quand on est
une femme on doit s'habiller comme eux
je pense que pardonner moi c'est un
énorme caillou dans la chaussure de
Didier Deschamps
98 ils ont tous pris la parole ils ont
tous défendu ils ont que fait Didier
Deschamps Didier des choses pendant la
parole quand il le voudra si la France a
tous ces problèmes qu'elle a aujourd'hui
c'est à cause des donneurs de leçons
tous les donneurs de leçons là je ne
citerai pas de nous mais c'est vrai
qu'on en peut plus
[Musique]
donc il y a plein de trucs qui vont pas
donc on les laisse comme ça
vous êtes hyper copines
avec mes copines
beaucoup mais j'en ai
6 dont vous faites partie et dont
Géraldine
c'est rare de trouver une amitié tous
les soirs
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'adore me confier à toi tu connais
toutes mes histoires on l'a vu on n'est
jamais d'accord sur les débats mais
c'est toujours un plaisir d'entendre des
arguments parce que tu argument très
bien c'est toujours un plaisir de se
faire défoncer par toi dans la bonne
humeur
néanmoins j'ai un gros problème avec toi
ce sont les fous rires ah oui tiens à
dire que Géraldine est à l'origine 99%
des signaux donc à cause de toi
la dernière partie tu es pas MP souvent
les 20 dernières minutes il y a souvent
des sujets graves absolument et les
trois là les deux là
Géraldine elle est relou parce qu'en
fait elle fait exprès elle se met comme
as et elle me regarde
aimerais un petit tour elle attend elle
attend
et là vous connaissez que moi on fait
plus de temps sur moi
non mais c'est insupportable émission se
transforme en calvaire pour moi
ni Michel Marie dans les yeux c'est
terminé
en plus pour des trucs très gras et à
chaque fois c'est insupportable qu'on
arrête pas de limiter dès qu'il arrive
on entend les mutation en fait
[Rires]
allez Jean-Michel maire Géraldine je
t'aime beaucoup c'est vrai parce que tu
es une femme de conviction et c'est vrai
que je dis pas que c'est rare du tout
mais c'est parfois plus difficile de
s'imposer quand on a une femme et qu'on
a une horde de gros macho autour de soi
comme ça qui est prête un peu te
défoncer
mais tu gardes toujours le cap et quand
tu as tu as quelque chose en tête tu
vois jusqu'au bout même si sous les
colibiers etc tu garderas le cap et ça
j'apprécie beaucoup même si je suis pas
toujours d'accord avec toi ce que j'aime
surtout en toi c'est que depuis le début
que tu es ATP PMB tu as eu un gros crush
sur moi
[Applaudissements]
ce que tu es très belle tu es un peu la
femme parfaite parce que pour un homme
tu aimes le foot tu aimes le poker tu es
bonne copine tu es fidèle en amitié et
en amour donc j'attends maintenant
qu'une chose c'est que Daniel trébuche
et en attendant qu'il trébuche je te
mets déjà la note de 8
[Applaudissements]
il y a quelque chose qui m'impressionne
chez toi c'est
ta à dire
à chaque fois
toutes les émissions tu as tout le temps
un truc à dire sur chaque sujet et pour
moi ça je trouve ça dingue parce qu'il y
a des sujets sur lesquels moi je j'ai
rien à dire et toi tu as toujours
quelque chose à dire alors je suis pas
contente à mon avis alors je suis pas du
tout d'accord avec toi ça c'est sûr et
on le sait toutes les deux mais tout ça
bah c'est quelque chose que j'apprécie
chez toi et au-delà de ça tu es
quelqu'un de solaire c'est toujours
souriante tu fais jamais la gueule tu es
belle j'admire ta carrière présente et
passer il y a un petit bémol ah c'est
que j'ai mis une note
[Rires]
j'ai enlevé quelques points ok alors
j'ai enlevé un point dans sa globalité
c'est énorme c'est pour tous les débuts
de fou rire qui sont à cause de toi je
le dis directement c'est quelque chose
que j'avais déjà prévu je savais pas que
que Guillaume allait le dire mais tous
les fous rires débutent à cause de toi
et c'est à cause de ça aussi qu'on se
fait déchirer par la suite que ce soit
Cyril ou les chroniqueurs ça débute de
toi un demi point pour Macron
un demi point pour le vaccin ça te fait
pas mal
c'est pas mal les notes
tu es belle tu es brillante tu restes
élégante même avec les costumes les plus
ridicules pour tout ça j'aurais pu te
mettre un œuf je dis bien j'aurais pu
parce que dans nos débats tu me déçois
souvent tu confonds
sur la religion tu vois de l'homophobie
partout tu es en matière de walkisme tu
pourrais être la fille naturelle de
Gilles Verdez et Sandrine Rousseau trop
bien et pour tout ça
se transforme en 6
[Applaudissements]
je te vois tu me fais craquer
de chocolat
je suis un escargot de l'enfant
je te jure sur escargot de bourgogne tu
as vu tout ce qu'elle dit tu as vu ce
qui sort de sa bouche c'est fou la magie
c'est dingue c'est fou
ouais
non je crois pas que c'est quoi déjà
[Rires]
j'ai les notes de votre fils
Géraldine 8 Gilles 0
Jean-Michel 4 bien noté Valérie 8 Hugo 5
Kelly 7 et qu'est-ce qu'il y a deux
[Rires]
il a fait un mix en fait entre les
chroniqueurs comme il est trouvé dans
l'émission plus ceux qui voilà ce qu'il
aime bien il m'a mis un coup de Fresson
pour jeudi il m'a dit ton poste est en
jeu
il m'a dit ouais
bon tu as une bonne note à toi
on peut parler de Géraldine
excuse-moi
impeccable
allez vas-y non Géraldine c'est la femme
qu'on aime détester et pourtant c'est la
femme qu'on aimerait tous avoir je pense
le jour c'est vrai c'est parce que parce
que
quand on la voit elle a un buvable elle
est des prises d'opposition c'est
branchées c'est pas possible elle
m'énerve et c'est très dur de
s'embrouiller avec Géraldine moi je vous
me défie de vous hein je vous me défie
les images quand vous embrouillez ça ça
envoie et moi j'aime bien parce qu'elle
peut être toute seule contre 100
personnes elle lâche pas l'affaire si
elle a son argument elle va au bout de
son argument je trouve qu'elle sert
beaucoup à l'émission C'est la personne
avec qui j'ai passé le plus de temps
assis que ce soit j'ai commencé a été
sur notre chaîne c'était pas la dernière
[Applaudissements]
ressusciter excuse-moi c'est que
j'essaye non non mais là donc je suis
très content d'être à côté d'elle même
si on n'est pas souvent d'accord au
moins j'adore et puis elle a un humour
pas possible un esprit pas possible et
quand on est un mec on se dit bah tu
vois ma nana si elle ressemble à ça ce
serait pas ça serait pas mal donc pour
ça je t'ai mis 9
allez Gilles oh Géraldine
on vous définir et surtout pour résumer
votre saison j'ai un seul mot classe
pas la classe internationale ça vous
l'incarnez mais c'est pas mon propos non
la classe de 3e que vous pensez diriger
le soir ici
[Applaudissements]
un bon point à votre copine
l'autre membre du gang des DDL là
que les autres ils prennent des coups de
règles sur les doigts
[Rires]
mais quand même Géraldine moi j'aime
bien quand vous êtes là parce que la
vérité éclate c'est l'exact inverse de
ce que vous pensez
maintenant pour la note je savais pas
quoi faire et vraiment je suis
sentimental j'ai cédé à l'indulgence
[Rires]
il donne sa note c'est drôle Géraldine
maillet bon moi je ne sais pas qui
avec qui je suis le moins d'accord entre
Gilles Verdez et vous je crois que
Gilles Verdez s'est détaché les
dernières semaines
vraiment c'est détaché parce que là ces
dernières semaines c'est vrai que comme
on parle plus de choses qui
vont
qui nous fâchent c'est vrai que on
commence à être d'accord sur pas mal de
choses
Géraldine
tu es tu as fait alors l'année dernière
tu as fait une magnifique saison et
cette année malheureusement
tu as encore fait mieux
c'est vrai qu'elle a fait mieux que
l'année dernière
déjà elle était déjà et là cette année
encore en fait elle a toujours gardé moi
je vais pas revenir sur ce que vous
dites ces arguments c'est c'est vrai
qu'elle se bat toujours pour ses idées
c'est vrai qu'on s'embrouille tout le
temps et on s'embrouille encore l'année
prochaine je viens pour ça
je viens pour ça non non mais c'est vrai
et je voudrais dire malgré les
embrouilles parce que parfois j'ai été
très dur avec Géraldine jamais derrière
après elle est énervée elle passe
vraiment autre chose et le lendemain
elle revient comme si de rien n'était
c'est ça et c'est là que c'est ça que je
vois que c'est une grande
professionnelle vraiment ça vraiment je
peux vous dire que c'est très très rare
parce que j'en ai vu des gens passés et
j'ai rarement eu des prises de bec avec
des chroniqueurs autant qu'avec
Géraldine et c'est vrai que Gilles et
Géraldine ont cette qualité même si
Gilles je le dis il est parfois même il
a l'air plus touché quand même voilà
même s'il dit rien mais Géraldine elle
passe à autre chose elle pleure jamais
elle va prendre son uber avec Valérie
Benaim
et puis elle parle de la recette des
boulettes à l'anus
voilà donc c'est vrai qu'elle s'en fout
total et après parce que je vous dis
comme moi je suis quand même le seul qui
reste avec le public après l'émission
puisque les chroniqueurs s'en vont comme
s'ils avaient un truc très important à
faire
et je pense que le public me demande
contredira pas
[Applaudissements]
voilà puisque les chroniqueurs
apparemment sont plus occupés que moi
n'habite plus loin voilà donc c'est vrai
que je les croise souvent quand ils sont
ils sont déjà en train de partir ils ont
déjà fait leurs affaires tout ça et
quand je repars je les croise sont
insérés croissant Géraldine et Valérie
même quand c'est on s'est pris la tête
ça ne
elle est tranquille quoi tu vois non non
Géraldine a fait une année
exceptionnelle et d'ailleurs je lui ai
dit vraiment je lui ai dit elle a fait
une année exceptionnelle et en plus
cette année ce qu'elle a rajouté c'est
qu'on rigole beaucoup avec et elle
arrache elle a rajouté aussi c'est
devenu aussi une sniper c'est ça que
vous voyez pas c'est qu'elle sort des
vannes donc elle a rajouté à son panel
non seulement elle avait des analyses
mais maintenant elle a rajouté les
vannes donc là elle peut sortir des
petites vannes on rigole c'est vrai que
même à la pub on va quand je vais les
voir on charit beaucoup Géraldine a fait
une année je vais dire presque parfaite
c'est pour cette raison que je vais lui
mettre la même note qu'à Gilles 975
[Applaudissements]
,3 c'est la meilleure note pour
l'instant si je virgule 3 je crois que
c'est ça
donc 6,3 ils sont en train de faire le
calcul 3 sur 10 je pense que Géraldine
je pense que Géraldine
[Musique]
la moyenne de Gilles la moyenne des je
crois que non
qui vous a mis dans la merde